what's up elimination it's Evan my one
word is believe and I believe in people
more than they believe in themselves and
my sincere hope is that if you see in
yourself what I see in you you'll be
able to change the planet I started to
believe life series to help us learn a
little bit more about ourselves grow
personally and ideally bring some of
what we learn about ourselves to our
business to have more success so today
we're going to learn how to take risks
rule number three is my personal
favorite and I'd love to know which one
you guys like the best also as you're
watching if you hear something that
really resonates with you please leave
it down the comments below I put quotes
around it so other people can be
inspired by it as well and if you leave
it within the first couple hours of this
video going live you have a chance to
win one of two daily prizes
[Music]
have you ever heard that advice to take
risks but you felt like well I don't
want to take risks no one likes risk
right no one wants to say when they wake
up in the morning I'm going to take tons
of risks today usually risk brings about
fear we're worried that if we take a
risk we'll fail
other people will judge us we'll look
stupid we'll feel uncertain or unsure of
ourselves and nobody likes those
feelings or those outcomes so as much as
people say take risks it's easy for us
to say no I'm not into that but we also
know intellectually that we can't grow
unless we take more risks that your next
level of success that leap from this
level to that level there's going to be
risk there you know it's from here to
there and there's that gap in between
you don't know is you take that leap if
you're going to do well that's the risk
you might fall you might fail you might
not do well but if you're not making
those leaps and taking those steps
you'll always be stuck where you were
yesterday and to grow we've got to have
a lot of courage to jump in those risks
new businesses start out small and so
you know it we it would be very easy for
say the person who runs our us books
category to say why are we doing these
experiments with things I mean you know
that generated you know tiny bit of
revenue last year
why don't we instead focus those
resources and that you know that all
that brainpower on this on the books
category where we which is a big
business for us and instead that would
be a natural thing to have happen but
instead inside Amazon you know when a
new business you know reaches some small
milestone of sales email messages go
around and everybody is you know giving
virtual high fives for reaching that
milestone and I think it's because we
know from our past experiences that big
things start small you know the biggest
oak starts from an acorn and you've got
to recognize you want to do anything new
you've got to be willing to let that
acorn grow into a little sapling and
then finally into a small tree and maybe
one day it'll be a big business on its
own another guy interviews man named
Kyle bass Kyle bass took thirty million
dollars gathered money together a lot of
money but other people's money turn in a
two billion in the middle of the
subprime crisis that's a very or a big
return you can say that in two years
right oh my god like how did you do this
is this work if this separate book you
even they open up the chapter of some of
the most historic books written recently
the gentleman who wrote Flyboys also
read one of the books in start that I'll
talk about Kyle bass doing this that's
incredible piece it's like it's like
being there with him but the way he did
it was he risk six cents to make it out
and just leverage that up so he could be
wrong how many times and still breakeven
15 he can't be wrong 15 times and make
money so what he's also smart as hell he
looked at things he evaluate things it's
more detailed I explained the book but
the core they all have in common is they
risk
for valuable return I want to make
whatever I'm doing harder I know that
sounds weird but I'm like how could I
make my job more difficult because in
the taking that risk to make it more
difficult I'll grow I'll give you guys
an example last weekend I had the
blessing to keynote a conference in New
Orleans some of you all were there it
was at the Superdome in New Orleans
which holds like a hundred thousand
people but they kind of spiced it in
half with a curtain and they had twenty
thirty thousand people in the audience
this was of the beachbody convention and
it was a blast now I could get up and
talk to 20,000 people pretty regularly
in my life I'm doing it again next
weekend it's what I do is a motivational
speaker right I'm used to doing that but
I could just go onstage do my thing and
get off and that wouldn't be serving the
audience as much and so I asked my
question myself how can I make this
presentation even harder on me so that I
can grow so I text two of my friends who
happen to be in that organization Tony
Horton many of you guys know he is kind
of the founder of and trainer for p90x
and chalene johnson who does piyo and i
text on both I said what's your hardest
exercise move that people usually can't
get because both those people going to
be the conference and this was a lot of
their superfans so I was like well lads
ago so Tony told me he's like the donkey
kick is the hardest one the donkey kick
is basically you do a handstand you kick
your legs out you land back plank
position you're right you're on your leg
through like threading the needle in
yoga and then you return and you do a
burping okay and chalene said well the
hardest one is like which calls the piyo
flip which is like imagine doing a
bridge right but then going to kind of
one arm and because like you're doing a
bridge this way and one arm goes that
way I mean it's not easy
so I decided in front of 20,000 people
to do those two moves back to back in a
suit so imagine doing a handstand in the
suit kicking your legs out threading the
needle then flipping over doing a full
extended bridge not easy but I did it
because it would be hard that make sense
part of the reason I got better as a
speaker is because I was pushing
so pushing myself I mean I used to be
it's very comforting and easy to give a
big speech and you know have a
transcript or all these notes to read
from but I said one day I'm going to be
able to get up on stage and give a
speech with no notes whatsoever now
that's hard that's not comforting it's
not easy but it's by putting challenges
in front of ourselves that we grow and
that's part of taking risks you know I
always say to people look if the only
challenges you're dealing with in life
right now are the ones that life dealt
you then you're not living a fully
conscious life yet and what I mean by
that is you're living a life of a
reaction if you're not moving and put if
you're not moving towards harder and
more difficult goals if you're not
giving yourself challenges if you're not
taking risks consciously then you're
just reacting to the world you're not
growing and so challenge yourself the
next time you're going to go do
something your art your career put
yourself out there try something make
that sales call how could you challenge
yourself to make that process even
harder so you get better both of us
right have given up a lot for our
careers and being successful and most
people don't like it when I say this
it has costs not having children are not
having friends or not having a social
life and so at some point you have to
decide whether that cost is worth it or
not
the question isn't really whether you
should take this risk really is it
it's what else do I really want to do in
addition to this right oh yeah and I
think maybe that's how I view the risk
is I'm not necessarily risking my
company if I decide to push it further
I'm risking my life it's not just
writing a check it's I now have to give
like a part of my finger yeah forever
because it's going to take more of your
time forever and so that's the trade-off
I truly believe that whatever you have
is a skill set if you want to start a
business
it cannot be outside of the horizon on
where you're at today and where you want
to get to so if you've absolutely come
into an industry you've never ever been
exposed to it talked to people in that
industry have any contact sport have any
experience whatsoever that is kind of
crazy
I really think it should be about you
the first leg of the business the first
testing zone the first revenue should
about 20% further than where you have
been in the past so maybe you've done
the work you work for another company
and now you want to do that as your own
business you've already got that part
the 20% is really starting the business
so I call it within the horizon of where
you're at and where you want to get to
and every time you get to that new level
the cool part is the horizon gets
further and further away and that's how
growth happens
thank you guys so much for watching I'd
love to know what did you think what did
you learn from this video that you're
going to apply immediately somehow to
your life or to your business leave it
down in the comments below I'm really
excited to hear from you and if you
leave a comment within the first few
hours of this video going live you might
win one of our two daily prizes I also
want to give a quick shout out to mark
Drager mark thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word and for being in the book your one
word and then taking that picture and
posting to Instagram
I really really appreciate the support
man and thank you for sharing it thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
let's love using
right now many of you know I have a
podcast about to change that podcast
from something that's been very
successful you know we had top ten for
over 100 weeks in my category
we're completely changing that up so for
those who listen to charge life that's
going to be switching up this weekend
cup to the Brendon show and it's
completely different it's a new format
we don't need to do it the old way
worked fine but part of taking risks is
making yourself evolve not being the
late comer to evolution I think so think
about how can you do something different
I'll give an example when we first
started my youtube channel back in like
2014 when we really started doing weekly
YouTube videos Travis had this great
idea he said you know what what if we
did our videos in black and white and
back then nobody was doing videos in
black and white on a weekly basis as
part of it so certainly not personal
development so we did it it was
completely different was a risk for us I
mean would it work going from color to
black and white in the modern era it did
and some of those videos took off I mean
million views two million views now some
of them entering the three millionth
view that that happened because we
decided to take a risk and be different
so how can you be different in your
category in your career in your your
field of interest whatever you're doing
how can you purposefully choose to
evolve and do something different
because that's a risk and sure not all
risks are rewarded but I'll tell you
what's never rewarded stagnation
I think risk is important for every
company I think it is the essence of
entrepreneurship whether you're the
smallest company in the world or like
Google the second largest company in the
world to take smart risks all the time I
run this experiment frequently with
groups where I give them two choices
choice a and choice B so choice a is you
get to deliver a million dollars of
bottom-line value to your company this
year guaranteed choice B you get to
deliver a billion dollars of bottom-line
value to your company this year but only
with one chance in 100 so everyone does
the mental math I say who wants to say
nobody raises
hands who wants choice B everybody
raises their hand it's got an expected
utility of ten times higher than choice
a and then I say who here believes that
your boss wants you to choose choice B
and not a single person in the room
raises their hand I mean these typically
are large multinationals who want to be
innovative and then I say you don't need
a lecture on innovation you need a new
boss you need a new context I really
think that it's the context that matters
we all inherently understand the taking
smart risks is the right thing to do now
what counts as smart what counts as a
risk is different in different parts of
a company or companies of different
sizes you know you can tolerate a PR
Fiasco much easier if you're a tiny
company because no one's watching you
than if you're a large company for
example so the calculus is different but
the principle is still the same the only
way to stay sharp to say growing to stay
relevant is to take smart risks all the
time when we took off risks we are being
confronted every single day with choices
we have to make that are going to change
our life forever those that believe in
the power of their dreams
end up manifesting them
[Music]
being brave taking risks following your
heart a lot of us are comfortable with
our life but through that comfort comes
a lot of anxiety a lot of worry a lot of
stress why because we are still living
the same old reason risk of all about
expansion embracing the news so you have
to get uncomfortable to feel happy
Rick
are all about uncertainty that's why a
lot of us stay away from well away from
but you see we are not free you're not
our projection of the unknown is what is
terrifying
[Music]
just imagine each other
tsunami you have 24 hours to live what
are you going to do
[Music]